[Music]
foreign
view a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what is
making the headlines with the guardian's
political editor Pippa Carrera and the
telegraph's associate editor for
politics Christopher hope and welcome to
both of you so to the front pages then
let us start with the guardian it
reports that plan strikes by nurses and
paramedics will go ahead later this week
with unions insisting the health
secretary Steve Barkley hasn't done
enough to resolve their disputes but the
eye has a more positive take on it
suggesting the offer of a one-off lump
sum payment could break the dead log
The Daily Mirror takes offense at the
notion that NHS staff should work harder
if they want better pay according to the
times the NHS could start treating
patients in temporary cabins in car
parks in an effort to tackle capacity
problems the Metro carries new polling
which found that roughly two-thirds of
respondents have a negative view of
Prince Harry
the express is once again outraged at
the Duke of Sussex this time at what it
calls his cruel depiction of his
stepmother the queen consort Camilla
while the male says Harry doesn't think
he'll ever move back to the UK
financial times has word of a possible
breakthrough in the long-running talks
between the UK and the EU over
post-brexit trade in Northern Ireland
and the star tells us there's a type of
solar blast called a space burp but
apparently they're not to be scoffed at
as they can cause electricity blackouts
well we're joined as I said by pipakura
and Christopher hope welcome to both of
you and Pippa let's go straight to the
guardian shall we NHS strikes to go
ahead as unions blame Minister for a
failure of talks ministerial meetings in
a number of sectors today is that at
least positive and were you expecting
more from these meetings
I think undoubtedly it's been regarded
by both sides as positive that they're
actually talking and they're talking
about P if you remember back before
Christmas the government was adamant
that while conversations could take
place and they were happy to meet with
the unions they didn't want those to uh
to be anything to do with pay
um that they had to be about conditions
or any other issue that working
conditions Staffing any of the other
issues uh which might come up in in the
round and there's been a shift over
Christmas and I'm sure we'll come on to
why that might be later but the all of a
sudden there's been signals from the
government with Richie sinak's speech
last week then a letter from Steve
Barkley to the health unions obviously
education and and [ __ ] are being being
done separately by their respective
departments but Health which has become
the most high profile one because of the
state of the NHS and the current crisis
that it's going through
um that unions were invited to speak to
Steve Barkley this morning and that in
itself I think could be regarded as a
breakthrough because it is obviously a
new approach
um there wasn't much movement in terms
of a sort of tangible offer on the table
by the end of those talks they were only
45 minutes long
um and I don't think anybody went into
them either the unions or the government
expecting resolution after after the
first round of talks which is why
um the unions said afterwards and we've
reported that the next lot of strikes in
the health sector are going to go ahead
of course we've got a ambulance strike
on Wednesday and the next nurses strikes
are due on January the 18th and 19th so
the strikes are on for now but there
will be more meetings over the coming
days and with health
um toward Health unions towards the end
of this week Steve Barkley at the end of
them said he would go away with the
Union's proposals about back dating next
year's pay settlement and and or a
one-off a one-off flat rate payment for
all health workers and speak to the
treasury so we'll see what they say
we'll see what they come back with
towards the end of a week okay that's
interesting isn't it because I think
Union unison's negotiator suggested
there was a [ __ ] of optimism and the
two issues you talked about there um
which the guardian talk about the lump
sum payment or the back dating of future
pay
um to end the nhss strikes might explain
some of the optimism we see on the front
page of the eye then Christopher hopes
rise of a breakthrough with a plan to
back date pay so what is it that has
changed is it all of those headlines
um over Christmas and New Year about how
woeful it was for staff and patients in
the NHS
it's definitely focused minds I think a
lot of people have been going home
seeing family and friends and and you
probably can't really see like another
amongst that group and they're saying
they're wondering well we can't go on
like this
um certainly before Christmas and and
people heard the same as I did that the
treasury was not budging on this the
entire conversation was all about 2023
2024 we expected an early meeting to
work out what those figures should be so
to have this conversation now to talk
about the current attraction year which
um sunak himself said that this year is
nearly over when the Daily Mail
interviewed him before Christmas so no
one expected this really
um and I think it shows how they are
slightly wobbling I think
um they're still 22 points behind
um the sunac bunch but Bounce has never
really happened because the the the the
the
um place in the party's place in the
polls hasn't pledged since it became uh
prime minister they were going to do
something I think a lot a lot of concern
on the tourist side might be if you
start giving in to this what about this
warnings about inflation and being this
being inflationary and that's why it
might be a one-off payment rather than
an increase in actual pay
and if we
go to unite negotiator who came out I
think many people pointing out that he'd
not actually been in the meeting but
suggested that it was going to be
performance linked any benefits they
received and his outrage that the health
secretary told struggling NHS workers to
work harder he said effectively that
they can't work harder they're already
well past their hours already
um pepper
yeah well I mean I think the point that
the United were in the talks but this
particular individual wasn't and came
out looking as though he was or sounding
outraged was slightly misleading
um unite anyway I think it's the most
sort of uh political shall we say of the
of the unions and also represented
compared to the other unions
particularly GMB Unison obviously the
RCN the Royal College of Nursing a
relative a relatively smaller number of
Staff in the NHS which is primarily a
private sector Union uh rather than a
public sector one but um the point that
that unite was making was that it was an
insult to
um to their workers to suggest to NHS
workers you know many of whom we've seen
on our screens over the last few weeks
and in you know in real life in our own
personal engagements with the NHS
whether it's hospitals or GPS work
incredibly long hours and work
incredibly hard and the suggestion from
unite was well you know this isn't a
factory and you can't it's actually an
insult to suggest that you know they
need to increase productivity however I
think it's really important to say that
the government probably wasn't meaning
individual workers need to work harder
or put in longer hours it's more about
the state of the NHS system that they
regard that the system as it is at the
moment isn't as productive or as
efficient as it could be
um and it does feel a little bit tone
deaf because obviously
um Frontline workers are really you know
overstretched and overworked
um but I do and I think probably that's
a communication problem on the part of
the government that they should have
made clear for talking about
productivity and efficiency that they
they should be highlighting the fact
that actually it's about in their view
uh making making uh life easier really
for those on the front line making it
more efficient to make the systems work
better rather than sort of you know
flogging people to the you know working
them to the Bone
um as some of the unions or this Union
in particular seems to have interpreted
um that that push that push for us so
um I think there's a communication issue
here I can understand why the government
wants to look at NHS reform productivity
and efficiency but I think they need to
be very clear that they're not talking
about the effort that's put in by the
individual workers that are currently
considering going out on strike again
because the mood music was for from some
people is very much that already the
health service sucks up nearly half the
nation's wealth and how much more do
does it need I mean so so what does need
to happen then
well I mean that's a big question Anna
for us for for
um you know of a Monday night I think
what we would say at the telegraph is
needs to be a complete rethink of how we
fund Health in this country uh maybe a
royal commission uh maybe um one where
you have the input from both labor lib
Dems the Tories
um to work out how we do it do we start
charging for GP appointments to stop the
missed appointments which cost you you
know just so much um do we do do do we
do do we do go towards a two-tier Health
Service as has been discussed in
Scotland these are the these are the
ideas you've got to talk about because
it is now draining this country of
resources half a time and it's so
inefficient there's a guy called Tim
Briggs Professor Tim Briggs he's come in
to try and uh he runs a great thing
called get it right the first time
they're trying to work why do some
trusts perform worse than other trusts
there's also all sorts of ways to be
more efficient that doesn't mean work
harder but work you know a bit more a
bit smarter to use that appalling term
but that's the idea but it's a huge job
of work and of course they are dealing
with the with the Fallout from the covid
pandemic and the big delay in operations
yes and if you take
you to you take my just quickly again
um a first person account of an a e
doctor I had to declare a patient dead
on the waiting room floor in front of
his wife and strangers and then we go to
the times Pippa overloaded NHS turns to
cabins and car Parks well they already
treat in cabins and car Parks don't they
lay tests and uh and and situations like
that but what is the point the capacity
genuinely is too small right now when
you have multiple infections underway
like covid and flu
yes and then it's just obviously
contending with stuff shortages and
record waiting times the suggestion is
that temporary cabins could be set up in
hospital car Parks specifically to ease
pressure on a E's where it which is
where we've seen some of those awful
images and stories from over the last
few weeks of patients uh being being
treated in corridors and in in public
areas and sleeping on Floors while they
wait to get treated and the big issue
here is of course the number of hospital
beds and you know we've spoken to
hospitals right across the country and
I'm sure Chris is his team at Telegraph
will have done the same and you know
capacity for hospitals in a sort of a
normal period might be sort of 85
percent uh 90 hospital beds full well
you know they write up some of the big
hospitals are right up to to 99.5 and in
some cases over 100 capacity
um there's a it's very difficult for
them to try and create that space and
part of the issue of that is is getting
people out of Hospital neither back to
home or um is as often the case because
it's as often elderly people in hospital
obviously because them is vulnerable and
getting them into Care Homes and there's
this package announced overnight by last
night by the by the health secretary
which I think was 50 million pounds more
to to to be able to discharge
um sorry no it's 250 million pounds
wasn't it more to be able to discharge
uh people into Care Homes but the
problem there is this the shortage of
Care Home workers
um so there's not necessarily the space
that they might envisage so you know
it's a there will be a short-term
solution for right now and obviously the
government's looking at cabins in car
parks and the way that we had during the
pandemic for jobs and like you say for
eye tests and so on but longer term
clearly there needs to be a structure a
really sort of you know written Branch
look at um at capacity in the NHS and
not just in the in hospitals themselves
as politicians have argued and as
politicians but you know people in the
health office have argued for years you
can't take the NHS in isolation it has
to be the Health and Social care system
and we've had big promises from the
government
um from this government from the last
government particularly from Boris
Johnson talking about fixing the the
social care problem facing the country
on the steps of Danish Street when he
took over you know here we are you know
three years on and and still social care
is as much as a crisis It Ever Was you
can't separate it out from the NHS if
you go into solve the NHS problem on
capacity you have to look at Social care
as well
and this is going just quick just very
quick sentence saying Christopher I know
you wanted to come in
totally right on what they were saying
and that's why they're trying to move
several thousands of people out of
hostels now
um and release them to use that term
that uh Steve Barker you'd get them out
get them into somewhere safe in homes
and try and free up bed space in these
actual hospitals okay and we didn't even
talk about strain train strikes and all
that um the rmt's leader Mick Lynch uh a
little quiet for him but we'll no doubt
talk more later on and lots more still
to come to including is Prince Harry's
portrayal of his stepmother
unnecessarily cruel discussing that next
foreign
[Music]
ER and Christopher Hope from the
guardian and the telegraph welcome back
to both of you
um Christopher should we go to the
financial times now and this is the
Breakthrough in talks with Brussels over
Northern Ireland
um described as technical but important
so take it away
yes and this is what was not was not
what was expected when James Kelly the
foreign secretary met with maros
ceskovic the European commission vice
president in charge of the talks it
wasn't Michelle barnier if you remember
back from your brexit days
um but yeah they are they're looking at
access right T Systems this is all about
trusted Trader status these ideas which
have been around for a long time the
first moved to die if I Remember rightly
by the ERG the European research group
of Tory MPS and about 2017 2018 and then
were discarded so this shows I think a
degree of trust
um which hasn't been there before but in
the UK in London and Brussels and the
Brussels the EU and bustles and that's
really been demonstrated by this I've
been well during the break trying to get
hold of colleagues of mine uh the dup in
Belfast and the spokes in there are
being very cool about what's happening
here they're saying that it that they
must they must replace
um with Arrangements that restored the
you the the the north lands place within
the UK and not to go anything against
that so the concern is that well there
might be a deal on data sharing and
that's agreeing that whatever is in a
lorry is in a lorry rather rather than
unpacking it you know it's there you
trust each other there's your further
agreement I think for the dep to be
happy what's driving this of course is
President Biden's trip to the UK to Mark
the 25th anniversary of the Good Friday
agreement in March and that's an
agreement that's the deadline we've
managed to the foreign foreign office it
matters less I think to people some
people in Northern Ireland who just want
the best deals for themselves that's
interesting isn't it that it's a Biden
visit that will eventually drive a
solution to this what seemed an
intractable problem let's go to Daily
Express still talking about Harry feels
like days doesn't it but there's been
lots more interviews obviously broadcast
Pippa
yes the Daily Express goes on Harry's
cruel attack on Camilla suggesting that
it crosses the red line
um this obviously is reference to the
latest stinging criticism from Prince
Harry
um uh towards a member of his family in
this case uh Prince Charles's Prince
Charles's King Charles says sorry King
Charles's wife the Queen the queen
concert he Harry his in his book accused
her of sacrificing him and his brother
to rehabilitate their image by trading
information with the media when she was
trying to win public support after her
affair with Charles now there was of
course historically quite a sort of a a
long transition in in Camilla's
reputation with the public she was she
was the Baddie for a long time because
she was um Charles's mistress for a long
period and the public sympathy Lee with
Princess Diana at that point and then
when they got together and there was a
concerted and long-term campaign to win
over public support for her and um and
you know she succeeded in that and a lot
of people if you'd asked in 15 years ago
whether they thought that Camilla could
ever be Queen would have said absolutely
not and there was barely a fuss about it
when they announced um
sorry for interrupting you there we uh
we need to get together but lovely to
see you both for now thank you both very
much pepper